en el campus de la universidad de
tsukuba una de las diez mejores de japón
se encuentran los invernaderos donde el
profesor hiroshige sura ha hecho crecer
un nuevo tipo de tomate conocen cara de
tocora de mantenga a lleva todo esto de
aquí hasta allá son tomates con una alta
cantidad de gavà con botón y ataquines
tres de
éstos son los tomates normales que
usamos para el experimento
como puede ver se ven iguales se va
curando
el agua es un ácido presente
naturalmente en las frutas tiene efectos
benéficos para el sueño y la presión
arterial los investigadores japoneses
recurrieron a la edición del genoma
modificaron el material genético de un
tomate sin añadir nada del exterior esta
es la diferencia con los transgénicos
utilizando la técnica de las tijeras
moleculares los japoneses cortaron una
hebra de adn en la que estaba
especialmente presente este ha sido tan
buscado
y luego consiguieron reinsertarlo en
otra parte del mismo tomate está
modificación del genoma lo hace más rico
en ácido gavà estos tomates son vendidos
en línea desde septiembre a 20 euros el
kilo el cable del precio de los tomates
en los supermercados
como estamos utilizando una técnica
nueva y acabamos de empezar todavía no
tenemos muchos por eso el precio es un
poco elevado
pero en japón las verduras son caras y
el precio de nuestros tomates es sólo un
poco más alto que el de los tomates
normales de alta calidad
desde el pasado mes de mayo se está
llevando a cabo un experimento a gran
escala 4000 voluntarios recibieron
gratuitamente plantas de tomate con
genomas editados en su pequeño huerto
cerca de tokio mi eco llama ya ha
cosechado miles de estos famosos tomates
y mi familia y mis amigos dicen que
estos tomates son buenos y que se
sienten mejor de salud cuando los comen
y tema así que efectivamente creo que
poco a poco se irán extendiendo en japon
diariamente la jubilada registra sus
datos de salud casi 1 de cada 3
japoneses sufre actualmente problemas de
presión arterial culpa y una dieta
demasiado rica en sal
como los tomates esta tarde almuerza con
su hermana también apuesta por estos
tomates modificados una comida en la que
todos los platos contienen los frutos de
su huerta buen provecho
y
el sabor del tomate es muy fuerte se
siente la acidez y el dulzor que además
la edición del genoma y los productos
transgénicos no es lo mismo si uno
entiende esta diferencia no hay nada de
qué preocuparse la técnica utilizada
aquí es diferente a la de los productos
transgénicos si se entiende el matiz no
es algo preocupante
por ello japón distingue claramente de
los productos resultantes de la edición
genómica y los productos transgénicos y
no obliga a los fabricantes a mencionar
el proceso en el empaque esto ha
despertado las sospechas de las
asociaciones de consumidores en los
estantes de esta feria agrícola todo es
local y orgánico
un mercado en el que no se quiere oír
hablar de tomates modificados y mil sino
valero lleno
que los políticos los investigadores
digan que es bueno no significa que
debamos fiarnos
algunas personas creen que estos
productos pueden causar nuevas alergias
no estoy convencida de que sean seguros
y
según una reciente encuesta realizada a
40.000 japoneses casi la mitad no
consumiría productos editados
genéticamente
la tonalidad productos que no queremos
comer y que van a llegar al supermercado
voy al supermercado sin pensar así que
me asusta no conocemos los riesgos no
sabemos cuándo van a llegar a los
mercados
cuántos japoneses han comprado ya los
tomates del futuro en la universidad
tsukuba el profesor es urano nos lo dice
es un secreto comercial pero por primera
vez abre las puertas de su laboratorio
bajo tierra deseando este es el
laboratorio donde se traen los brotes
editados genéticamente para su cultivo
pueden entrar en el laboratorio ya se
está trabajando en nuevos proyectos y es
que la visión genómica permite imaginar
tomates más resistentes al calor guau
las heladas más o menos ácidos
azucarados o enriquecidos con vitaminas
modificaciones que pueden aparecer
naturalmente y que no deberían causar
miedo
el riesgo es el mismo que con los cruces
normales en tomates normales
al comerlos tenemos problemas de salud
es la misma cuestión
estos tomates pronto estarán en las
estanterías de los supermercados
japoneses y puede que sean exportados la
comisión europea está estudiando la
posibilidad de comercializar los
actualmente están prohibidos en europa